[Laughter]
you
we also have in the system we also have
something like that chain which is
perfectly happy to return a single array
without any Association wrapping I
understand that I understand that so I
mean I'm saying that okay fair enough
but I mean okay alright let's have a
look at the design of this thing in
general and then yeah we need to
specifically discuss input-output at one
point so yeah okay so here the use of
variables here is you know if you can
successfully compiled them great I think
we want to have this general notify
concept as a way to signal you know what
the visual appearance should be that
really has nothing to do with the you
know the evaluation control flow that
make sense yeah it's it's a grouping
mechanism yes yes that's right I mean
it's something where you know what to
put in a single node and by default
probably you know yeah I'm not quite
sure what the semantics are whether by
default that I think by default the
things are all in one node and this
notify thing basically says here's
something here's the things inside this
notify there aren't inside another
notify are their own separate node so
you want to switch to toggle this on and
off no no no I'm saying the following
I'm saying let's say we have F of G of H
of I of J of X okay okay actually I
should write this out in a different
form I should write F hg @ h @i @ j at X
okay so if you wrote that I'm saying
that's just one blob okay by default
it's just one they're all in one blob
but if on the other hand you put in here
something like you know notify here you
put in another notify here then what
that would do is in that chain
would say break this so don't have by
the time you get to that next notify
actually that one might be irrelevant
that one at the front might be
irrelevant but by the time you get to
this one
the I Jake IJ is no longer part of the F
G H node
it's it's own separate node but do you
do like that we do this we set or you
you are suggesting that we actually have
an explicit wrapper which is I'm not I'm
saying don't do it with that I mean you
can do it with set if you want to as a
convenience but don't generally and
require people to use set if you roam
and I went back a lot of time on the
tree parsing of this thing and post
parsing and expression parsing in one
reason why design useful is to also to
nail down a bit of evaluation semantics
of this beast well okay that's a
different history but what I'm saying
here is that this is just um I mean this
is just in terms of the visual display
and the question is you know can you
write a functional program and have it
visually displayed appropriately and I'm
kind of insisting that you be able to do
that and I agree with you that having
the variable assignments cause an
additional node to be created is a fine
and dandy thing right I'm just saying
have something else that's able to do
that as well that make sense yeah it
makes sense some sometimes you may want
to group as well like I wondered if when
you put a viable assignment you always
want a node and only if you've got you
know this is the problem if you if
you're hacking you know variable
assignment has nothing to do with making
a node let's call a spade a spade right
but you could take the heuristic that
variable assignment defines a new node
and the heuristic might not work all the
time so you know perhaps we want
something and maybe we shouldn't talk
about that design right now but maybe we
want something I would say that the core
idea is some kind of notify except I
don't really like
name you know that would be the core
thing that defines a note so you can
always get a note here by saying x
equals notify you see I'm saying
but now whether the it by default
creates a node when you do x equals you
know it seems like a reasonable thing to
do by default particularly if there's a
way to switch it off makes sense yeah
yeah yeah they also sometimes we have to
put a node no matter what right now
cleaning a layer has to meet so no node
select as well once you've got a layer
object it has to be its own node yeah
right I mean the layer objects aren't
look these things a net function can
just be a blob I mean in that function
with with just generic things to compile
could just be a blob but as soon as
there's another layer
it's a node am I correct yeah yeah yeah
I mean potentially okay I wanted to
understand also that we potentially be
net function inside
yeah yeah okay okay fine so I agree that
that you should have a toggle to show
the code on the graph and that's the UX
thing here makes sense yeah
um okay as some questions on our live
stream here Ethan is saying topper is
net function fully custom layers local
net trim with remote AWS kernel um let's
just understand what we're doing here so
net function we think we're doing fully
custom layers that's um a story if I'm
not mistaken with the compiler and so on
is that right is that yes yeah that's
the next topic topic on this agenda okay
well we're in luck there
okay local net trimmers remote AWS
kernel um the batch job training on AWS
is absolutely an active thing that is in
a good State I think have you guys been
using it yet the stuff jesse has been
building don't think so no really well
you should be I mean so that's the
that's this whole batch job submit
mechanism for Amazon batch jobs
hmm you really should try it you guys
should be using it yeah I mean I think
scimitar is somewhat aware as well we
know it seemed to okay so SP here on our
live stream is talking about input
windowing neither general input window
eg a sparse weight matrix functionality
more flexible and processing then
translation a variant convolutional
layer processing oh I see so you're
saying in the well I don't know does
that max net support that do you
understand what's being asked for so
instead of instead of being a block like
a block map across I mean in this is
asking for a more complicated way of
sampling you know a sparse weight matrix
being the thing that you are sampling
with in a convolution layer I don't
think we support sparse array and I
think it makes that support sparse array
you know I'm excellent as something
about sparse dancers right know exactly
what's the color age but but it's the
issue here is windowing not not the main
data the issue is you have an array it's
dense I assume but you have the spider
that's crawling over it and it has long
legs the generalization of convolution
kind of yes yeah that's how dilated
convolution look like well so let's take
that offline and maybe you guys can
answer that question um okay George is
saying best new functionality will be
support for GPUs on Mac OS you're
telling me I don't understand that you
know I've been watching the computer in
the street for watching participating in
the computer industry for 40 years now
the the the the Mac's not supporting
GPUs is just strikes me as nuts and I I
don't know what's gonna happen with
Apple announcing you know it's moved to
ARM processors that's a that's just a
weird thing and I don't know whether we
have any this is a kind of an industry
forces issue that you know we have
certainly made people aware of what we
think but you know quite why those
decisions are being made I don't know I
don't know that anybody has any comments
on this here um this question from
Freeman does the neural network on GPUs
yes absolutely our framework works on
GPUs how to tell the framework which
kernels to fuse and understand that
comment GPU training for Mac yeah I mean
everybody's asking about this I you know
what does Apple have to say about this I
mean people must ask this on Apple news
groups all the time
what is Apple saying about it
yeah I don't know I don't know exactly
except that yeah I said that he's not
very developed well I know that I mean I
I've talked to the arm folk about this
and they're sort of adventures in in
trying to get libraries developed and so
on and I you know there's a place where
Intel has really done you know a lot of
work and what how it works yeah what one
thing we can do and we should work on
that is to provide just in France of
network on Mac GPU which I think should
be should be easier you know things like
with honor on an excellent time library
something like that that we could
include in our in our product and then
you kind of convert our network to you
know from a mix net to onyx and then run
I see well so that pipeline is one we
can build we should absolutely do it I
think yeah we useful for like you know
imagine if I imagine don't if I could
run on the GPU or well what's trying xkz
okay so I mean what you're saying is now
that we have an onyx export we should be
able to take our network export it to
onyx import it into the Apple whatever
it is core ml framework or something and
run it there is that correct that's no
that's something different
that's again yeah I mean definitely this
will be a possibility for people to
export a network but also we could have
a construct like excel net or something
like that would basically do the entire
procedure in the session ourselves
exactly I'm sorry what are you saying we
can basically do the entire procedure
that a general descripted in the in our
session ourselves like instead of
exporting the network to a file
oh no no I understand that completely I
was I was only saying that conceptually
oh yeah conceptually yeah conceptually
except I don't think we need to go to
Coronel it might just be on an X and
then the runtime would work in me
platform
I assume listen this is a high priority
thing you guys need to try this yeah you
won't be able to train but at least you
would evaluate no I think that's already
very useful yeah um so there's some
comments on our live stream about this
Ethan
saying you can use rock em to run Amex
net on Radeon there's several words that
I don't know what they are so I can't
comment on that um some push is saying
they should make trusted microprocessors
not graphics processors
yeah well solve the physics of
microprocessors they haven't gotten much
faster in a long time it's all been in
the organization of the you know I'm
amazed that servers we bought 10 years
ago we really it's only if we bought
servers again today they'd only be 20%
faster
um it's it's a surprising thing um ok
let's get back to this and we'll go back
to some of these other comments later um
so okay so we've got we're talking about
this okay so let's talk about net chain
what's what's this so you're saying net
extract so Isis your your point is only
that this thing is behaves like one of
these layer objects yes yes although we
could also I mean for reason we might
discuss after media output make it only
behave like a classic Network when you
do net graph you know and then it
converts to a net graph and then you can
do whatever you I'm not quite
understanding this I mean in other words
you're saying okay so let me let me take
this apart so the question is is net
function a single lump or is it
something that can be treated and
extracted as separate elements in a net
graph or in that chain is that really
the question kind of emotional question
but yeah basically it is not a single
lamp yes it is inside it's it's it's
also a net so that so there's a notify
thing that I'm talking about has more
significance than than merely the
display that's what you said yes yes yes
yes yes and for sure when you do net
graph net from train it will convert to
a net graph that is exactly like any
other node graph okay so hold on hold on
hold on this is important because you're
saying that that really what we need to
do this this notify thing that I've
talked about
is really something with semantic
content it is something that is defining
I mean and I'm not not quite sure then
if that's the case why you're not just
having another net function y that
notify isn't just another nested net
function zero I'm saying so in other
words every s function yeah completely
I all make sense okay and I think in
this pipeline that I was defining above
while I think there's a generalization
of all of this that can be used for
arbitrary functional programs to be able
to display block diagrams of them I
think for these purposes one way to
achieve that would be just to wrap it in
a net function here which I think would
just work in this case here if I'm not
mistaken this would be if the net
function is defined well the only issue
here is this would have to be a function
composition and then that final
application is different
never mind I'm sort of talking to myself
here that as far as defining this
function it would have net functions in
the stack of things defining that
function right that function is then the
way that's applied to an argument is a
little different for an hour you know
never mind it's okay that's I'm just
dealing with the parenthesis of how that
works
did you understand us yeah I mean that's
a big question about these net function
working like any other function or is it
wrapping in a session the output that's
the different issue right we need to
address okay and that's the multi or
multi output thing but what we're
basically saying is this is what the net
function this is the life of a net
function isn't defining something like
that which is then going to be applied
like this see what I'm saying so the net
function lives in this functional piece
the application to a final argument is
done all together as opposed to this
case here where if I were to break this
here right it would do absolutely
nothing
it would just what does that do that did
do something now I'm actually oh yeah
yeah that that does the wrong thing
right because that has the innermost
thing is a J there do you see what I'm
saying
it's not exposing itself um to to get
what I'm saying yeah you need to mix um
some composition with the application
right that's what I'm saying that this
is what we are doing is is that's the
sequence that corresponds to your net
function not this sequence here okay
right okay so that's that's a way to
define so in this case then sub 3 comma
3 would get to the net function lump and
if you want to get inside the net
function lump you do another extraction
on that correct so you could nest net
functions and then you do essentially
part extraction down the sequence of net
functions although any given net
function its innards are really just I'm
a little confused by that I mean it's
going to have some innards that are
other net functions and some innards
that are not net functions how the noise
right now he's only yes yeah in the end
I understand that right right but so
maybe what it does is it has to treat
the things which are not explicitly net
functioned inside the net function as
you know as if they were layers and I
don't know exactly how that works but I
don't think this part extraction thing
is the most important issue I mean when
right ok all right what is this
what on earth is this thing this is to
represent parameters learn about
parameters to be precise that we call
array in our language and how do you
represent because you're not going to
only put classic layers right when you
can put linear layer you can put
convolution layer in it but also a way
to define parameters and then you know
do things with parameters and the
current way that we could do this is
with constant array layer although it's
a little bit weird because as it sound
like a teachable layer by the way yes
at a separated topic that would put just
below that we also want to rename
constant array layer just array layer
that's separated topic we think it's a
bad name and actually it's the best
tenant led also think I mean a few
Sebastian think it's a bad name so let's
try to understand here what this boy can
you yeah can you remove the array random
real I don't know why I did that this is
a detail like exactly I know I'm just
gonna not look at it I'm not gonna
remove it because I don't know K um any
Chinese Asian okay you can put if you
out but it's definitely not the general
case the general case is just net array
and thence the dimension dimensional
array okay until then what you expect so
if I did for example if I did let's say
net initialize yeah of net array you
know four five six yeah I would get a
random somehow random array four by five
by six array is that correct
definitely there is still the question
when you use when you evaluate net array
that is initialized in not in your
network or not in a function does it
evaluate to an array or does it stays
with a net or a wrapper but acts like an
array all the time this is the don't
know this I would have thought it would
be more convenient to have it just be a
net array like that and you know have
some normal mechanism or something to
take it out because I don't think that's
an important case to have it you know
the escaped net array doesn't seem like
you know the primary cases when it
hasn't escaped yes yes definitely so the
primary thing so we we have two
possibility open we are not preferring a
little bit any net wrapper I think in an
opera is what the other um you know I
think that's what the other things do
the other net related things do that and
I think that's probably the right thing
now oh I see okay so you've talked about
not to initialize
Oh purple puffle okay so this is the
question of if it initializes what does
it initialize to which would act like an
array right freemen is suggesting
looking at flux and all the way I'll let
somebody else do that um so and I hope
you guys do take notes of these things
because they're good suggestions here
somebody make a note of that yes um keep
track of all the comments okay so you
know this net array will actually be
compiled to a constant array layer in
our framework so what you see on the on
the graph this a is actually a constant
array layer that we should probably Rene
because it's not constant it's like
don't call it that and why don't we just
call it a net array if that's what it is
why is it compiling to anything I mean
why don't we just say there's a thing
called a net array that because it's not
a layer this eraser layer layer you need
to apply something to it so you need to
apply it to something exactly which in
the case exactly yes which in the case
of constant array layer is nothing so
it's a way to probably I understand
nothing I mean if you say constant array
layer if I'm understanding correctly if
I say constant array layer of six and I
say net initialize of this right why
does that not work east towards the list
yeah okay and now I say apply that to
nothing exactly then I'll get a then
I'll get an array so if we don't
introduce this new symbol net array we
would have to use in the net function
concentrate layer of whatever dimension
and then put this empty
Oakland close bracket so what I mean
what purpose would we have to put that
you know today we want to we want to
give it less I to available this is a
value of this array that then is no I
understand yeah right
so I I agree with you I think having a
net array that isn't a layer that
because a layer as you're pointing out
as a function to be applied to an input
array to do something whereas a net
array just is what it is and yeah I mean
that seems right to me which was
Jerome's really suggestion so right you
know right so I don't understand in
what's tagged of what's learn about what
what is it a teachable layer and what is
not a teachable layer in in the output
display we are tagging that right I
don't know how we tag that the names
don't distinguish am I correct
no okay so I mean it was an example of a
learner belayer non-top threading layer
element-wise layer aggregation layer
okay okay okay let's look at the multi
output case which by the way there won't
be so many because you know there's like
there's this constant array and then
this element wise and so on and then
there will be net function and I think
will be over soon of this no now
teachable area because it's basically
wrapping regular code you know there's
no parameter is just function anyway so
yeah also do
Milty outputs our suggestion was that
you have if it's a military output you
have to write an association in the net
function that was our suggestion I mean
in the network and this is a multi input
case here input yeah I was talking with
the output that's easier case yeah I
agree I mean if you want multiple output
then if you put an association there I
agree and if you want multiple input the
question is how you tell it that this is
a multi input net function as opposed to
an ordinary net function and I think the
most plausible thing would be something
like oh boy I mean I could imagine a
syntax I'm not sure I let necessarily
like the syntax something like net
function and then a list of keys so key
one key to arrow function it's not my
all-time favorite but it would work I
think I mean the named argument of
course would work with hash Bob as
Claire this is no problem I'm sorry what
do you mean that I'm just saying that
that tum right but I'm saying that this
is what that you have two choices either
it is a function that is applied
positionally to things and maybe we
could say something like I mean this
should be work like curry right we need
to go look up how curry works but
something like this could say it's a
four argument function expect four
arguments am I making sense so if we
look at curry for instance Oh
it shows how unmodern I am but but you
see what it's doing there so this is
saying
yeah so this is kind of the same idea
this is this is giving a template for
what the structure of the input should
be like and then I mean possibly even
Curie applied is usable I'm not sure if
it is but but you get the point I mean
it's it's something which is telling you
eventually you're going to feed this to
the function which you might have to
curry things somehow to get them into
that function I'm not sure if currying
is the right concept but you're going to
well okay okay okay hold on
one thing you could say is this is just
what you have what you do with multi
inputs you just do this and that way net
function doesn't know that it is
expecting Bob and Claire am I making
sense you just have to know that yes
yeah we were just I mean not terrible
yeah I think it's kinda this will I mean
this is our job there were some passing
some passing it we figure out it's no no
no it doesn't have to figure that out
because the issue is okay the only issue
is yeah yeah there is a need for this
thing the issue is when the arguments
are prepared for net function
what are they prepared as right are they
prepared as positional arguments net
function blah blah blah Open bracket
arguin out two or three or are they
prepared as an association the two cases
exactly Association we wanted to make
that function act exactly like the
function that is inside right well and
that would that would mean that they
would net function could also have
positional argument friend the rest of
the framework but when it's a major
issue with that
meaning a Gannett graph cannot take many
argument input you're saying that hash
input that it expects a hash input is
that correct yes
as opposed to a positional argument
exactly it's either just one argument on
a station or at least it's also accepts
early stuff but none of that because
what you've got here net chain then is
not in fact the equivalent of function
composition because it's messing around
with these hash input hash output things
right which functional composition would
not naturally do unless you have
something like a curry applied mechanism
where you say you know unless you have
something which says you know something
like Association applied okay of F which
packs and unpacks is that Association
mechanism does that make sense so in
other words what that's doing is it says
this is a function which normally would
just take f of X but Association applied
of F would do this it would feed to F
the Association input arrow X and it
would then unpack from F output arrow Y
or whatever it is see what I'm saying
you understand not understand okay so
look here's the definition of this this
is it says F of this right and then it
says take that and turn it into output
arrow blah okay so that thing that's the
definition right let me just put a you
know an X here or something that's not
always return decision it's it's gonna
vary what net Shane and the graph does
not return it returns either in a
session when you have many output ports
and you have only one how could port
well
hacked our there no no wait wait no no
it's not it's not it's not depending is
always the same net graph I think always
returns an association chain one or
there is an inconsistency if there is
one output it returns the output and if
there are two it as well yeah yeah okay
okay well so we've got to mess them so
we're gonna have to clean that up but
you understand what I'm proposing here
so this is a way of converting from
something which expects to take a
function to something which expects to
take and give an association yeah except
that he probably would be the other way
around right you would want to give well
I don't know it depends on these other
functions I mean we've got to clean that
up so you know look what you're telling
me is okay net graph and net chain you
say are inconsistent in whether they
return associations or just pure
expressions is that correct yes we net
change should be safe at least it cannot
have mu t out good no it can it will
change the in tournaments but the the
first layer kind of milk input and there
is our last layer like all the layers
are the same today they have to be the
same right
that shouldn't ok so listen we've got a
mess right so in the case of multi
output the you know well so let me ask
you it as a kind of demographic question
do these networks typically have multi
input multi output or do they mostly
have single input single output itself I
would say it depends it depends as a
whole maybe you can you know it really
depends like if it's there in a pipeline
you typically want to return multiple
things okay but it really depends on
your quiet line okay so let me let me
pull this back again if we're doing net
function with variable names that's how
we deal with multi input multi output
correct even with associations if we're
doing in this function with you know x
equals blah blah blah the
that's how we're dealing with multi I
mean are we in fact allowing you know
well they're just grouping okay the
input is AG bar is not foods load bar
that's the Association input I
understand but so if you wanted a okay
so if you want that to return multi
output you could say list XY equals if
it's positional right this is what I
really don't like the fact that this one
has an association now Putin is very
clear that is returning like named ports
never press in the middle of this thing
you don't know you're saying in the
middle of this you can only have single
variable like sort of data transport you
can't have or you could build one of
these things you could say x equals
something which is explicitly an
association and then elsewhere in this
code you could you know you could go
into that association in principle yes
if you want to create something that is
multi port inside you would do that yes
okay and your compiler will be able to
handle that I don't know if right now
but I remember we discussed so
conceptually we can handle this sexually
yes okay yes okay okay all right so
let's let's unwrap this little bit so
the issue is right now when we say
linear layer for example we have a bunch
of wacky stuff there where you can give
input you know you say input arrow
such-and-such output arrow such-and-such
were those unnamed ports to those
objects correct if there is only one it
was in this case you don't promote okay
but but you can say linear layer quotes
input equals um the
right yes go change the name though I'm
sorry you can't change the name of the
output port or input port in Guinea
earlier no in the subs you say quotes
input equals I puts in put arrow seven I
mean when you're giving the size of the
input the size of the output you can
give that in those layer specification
yes yes yes okay so okay so we have a
bit of a mess here um so let's try to
understand what to do so we've got these
layer objects which fundamentally apply
themselves to arguments but they also
have the ability to have named ports now
the idea of named ports gosh
yeah okay I mean Julia is sending me
something here it's just to have a -
basically this is a kind of syntactic
sugar that was added the beginning and
is just an example what you just
mentioned these these two works
indifferently okay okay I understand so
it treats so the sub value of
element-wise layer treats that as
equivalent somewhat bizarrely
and we could do the same thing with net
function the problem is that the element
was layer has a single input port named
input and now we enter the real more
freeform
where you could specify a function that
takes I know I know I know that's why
I'm suggesting that you know rule to
specify what it expects or an
association applied mechanism see what
I'm saying that is a sort of a
destructuring headdress so to speak for
that functional object
make sense you stand the idea no idea
but I'm trying to figure out like a
solution applied with so you just rely
in this because in one point of
association is that is not is like
ideally unordered you don't care about
doesn't matter but when you have when
you want to convert sequential input
into association or vice versa
well you have to order no you have to
specify the order in which the keys are
associated with elements of the list I'm
not sure this is exactly correct but the
main thing you're addressing here is
okay so the question is net function
you've got three things you've got net
function net chain net graph okay so the
question is to what extent is a net
function like a net
you've got net model as well what
doesn't that model do with this
there that's evaluates to a network so
we can forget it for this discussion so
in other words it evaluates to a net
chain or net graph exactly okay okay all
right
so okay so the question then is as we
connect together net functions all the
net functions taking in and giving out
associations with named that are like
named ports or is it a pure sort of
functional pipeline right that's the
question am i correct
yes broad strokes yes
okay so right now net chain and net
graph have some hackery that they can
execute as to the individual layers the
individual layers have a piece of
hackery that allows them to take both an
association and a naked expression yeah
okay that's gonna bite us at some point
now if you if you look at it this way
well fine fine I mean that's what look
we you know this is the nature of this
design trajectory is you know the goal
what you know our original design for
neural networks was something based on
code but we knew that that was
unexcusable five years ago so you know
we built the thing with layers with kind
of these specific blocks and you know
I'm not at all surprised that there's
aspects of that build out that aren't
what we want now and I think we should
fundamentally plan to you know we should
figure out what we want and then we
should figure out how to build the
bridge okay so in other words what is it
that we actually want for these things
do we want every object net function or
whatever to be on its own honor so to
speak taking certain structures of
inputs and giving certain structures of
outputs or do we want to somehow more
obviously expose the type signature
effectively of the thing I think that's
what it comes down to so I mean you know
one possibility is the net function just
does what function does which is I can
eat anything you know totally omnivorous
and it's up to you to destructure it
appropriately inside the function
right yeah one of the proposal so if you
have slot 1 slot 2 it will expect a
sequence of two things if you have our
it will expect an association right so
that's exactly what function does right
so that's not a that's not a foolish way
to do it now you know if we wanted to
wrap and I'm honestly that seems to me a
flexible way to do it and and you know
if you want to wrap essentially
type-checking around it that's a
separate thing that you can wrap around
I mean we don't have that with function
and we have surprisingly little need for
that with function so I I would tend to
favor that approach for net function
that it's just omnivorous so to speak
okay yeah so now the question is given
that what what do we do with net chain
and net graph do they I mean they
there's one problem mean this will force
absolutely the output of net function
not to be a layer though because we have
this layer semantics that they can take
properties as extra arguments like you
can say mmm the net Madhavi magenta Phi
which is the net image comma
probabilities so that's that that
already enforces the structure that the
input is always the first argument you
don't have this liberty of taking
sequences in okay so we need the if in
that model yet snap model that's an
outer wrapper thing is in a chain that
chain or n layer actually that has some
properties you can say that in a chain
of image comma top probabilities like
classifier I I understand so we need we
need to depart from from those heads if
we want to this freeform that function
has to be its own piece which I would
say I don't mind because I like the
similarity function and the fact that if
you take the function out of a net
function well it's not obvious to me
that
that met her request for net model it's
done in the right way so what you're
saying is that net model is given the
its primary input which might be an
association as the first argument it no
no Ned model then model evaluates when
it's graphed near train whatever
whatever it doesn't matter but I mean
that model
it's the sub value of net model whether
that's a net got whether they ends up
being in that chain or a net sub value
of that has you know what you're saying
is that basically what it looks like is
net model of blah of input come on
possibly you accept him like it so that
you're saying that's the structure this
is not true for every layer every
element that is in the framework so this
okay fine fine well that's important to
understand no exactly ever see is a
point to start right so let's do it
what would happen don't we have layers
that take multiple arguments don't we
have like addition layers that take
multiple arguments they are always
associations in other words this input
is always packaged as a single argument
is the input so even if it's adding
things so that means that we can't use
the function plus we say X plus y you
you can do you can do a threading layer
plus and there so let me understand and
inside a net function when you're using
these these layers right the second
argument of those layers is totally
irrelevant at this level it would just
mess things up completely if you put a
second argument in here yes inference
you you don't need you want to look at
the head basically yeah so that's it's
the only thing well but here you're not
just looking at the head you're
presenting something that actually has
an argument fed into it because that's
the structure of this color but indeed
would mess things around let me see the
head because so what you're saying is
anything that is from this framework
has to be a one argument function here
inside the net function and that it's
two argument form I mean this seems
wrong to me because to me the right way
to do this it seems to me is to have
some kind of head dress like mechanism
that is what tells it that you want meta
information just like you know we have
information that gives you meta
information about something different
from the thing itself so to speak that
makes sense right yeah that's one thing
which is the evaluation and something
where you're taking the yeah I think one
of the problems it is to freeform
because it is not just information it's
also linked to the evaluation you can
say vomit or haggle and and so on yeah
Kegel has known about us since the
beginning and used us the fact that if
they're not using us right now that's
their decision not ours I'm gone I mean
the point that you can do like a network
of an input and then ask for a specific
net port as a property so this this it
is very freeform that's that's one of
the problem here it's and the fact that
you ask for a net port as a property is
not a static thing is a runtime thing
for exam at port for what let's say you
have a complicated net graph you say
this is the input comma and you ask for
the specific output of a sub layer of
that that graph so the computation will
stop at that point and exit and give you
that result I understand that's a weird
piece I mean that's that's similar to
what I'm asking for with the sort of
meta data about you know it's similar to
saying top probabilities or some such
other thing right I mean probability
walls because it's property of the last
layer yeah so it's in that case you you
evaluate the whole thing and then you do
something associated with it right so
what you're saying is there's a way of
reaching in
to this object and asking for something
which isn't see here you are asking for
this right you've got that property or
you've got a net port you know
presumably here instead of this you
could say net port whatever is that
correct the net port of layer full and
the port to or the port output Oh so
that's just one of the potential
properties that you're asking for at a
meta level of the whole network yeah and
if you were to ask for that in the
innards of the network the whole thing
will fly out of control right it's a
property of the complete network after
it in tribal port we could make it work
right for the port we can definitely
make it work yeah but but it is
connected to the proper port yes but
that's not but you've got then a
different mechanism for connecting to
the port that isn't the Association
mechanism for Connect yeah it's a bit
weird also because visa is not static
again this is runtime and then we're
mixing stuff at is used at runtime with
stuff so to my mind what what we need is
you know we've got one thing which is
layers that are teachable etc etc etc
and we've got this thing where you are
taking the whole network and you're
asking for some unusual you know some
property of it that isn't just run the
network and give the result right and
that's something which as you say might
just you know affect the last layer or
it might reach into some named piece of
the thing and extract some net port you
know output so to my mind what that
needs is something where boy okay so you
know net model for example is a
higher-level construct
which by the way can take can contain
all kinds of meta information in here
before it ever gets supplied to its
actual input on the other hand
oh let's see I mean sorry crazy idea
maybe one problem is the actual layers
like we don't have these problems
because the function you are the support
or not so what if net function by
default doesn't take layer symbols but
just you know a layer wrapper that
contains all the parameters and that's
it then it does it has doesn't have to
have a semantics of a layer you don't
have to support second arguments
properties or such sorry I'm got
distracted so I'm being told I'm two
meetings late here go ahead
whoops I don't know if it's I mean one
ideas it was floating around all the
time is why do we need all these symbols
for layers like and we don't have
problem with Max because max we know
what it does and if you have a function
that I don't know blur blur it's okay we
don't support it period no I understand
so I mean removing going going to a
situation where we don't have element
wise layer it's just the function seems
like a much better scheme to me yeah
like layer an inside layer you have an
element where I say with its properties
and that's it and then you don't have to
support any port or anything because
that's just a symbolic representation of
that computation I agree I think that's
a reasonable direction going and I don't
think that's a look the fact is this is
[Music]
um okay I think the thing we should be
thinking about here is we had an
original plan five years ago for how we
were gonna do this
we decided that plan was not executable
because of the state maybe was more than
five years ago now um that we decided
correctly that that was not executable
right now right which is why all these
functions are tagged as experimental
yeah and the you know we decided to
execute five years earlier knowing that
that was not the perfect design that we
would want so I think now is the time
now we're ready to do the design that we
and we should probably look at the
original design documents we had because
they were pretty much along these lines
um you know let's figure out where we
want to go figuring out a bridge to the
existing framework is not going to be
difficult and you know we'll keep the
existing layers and things running
forever and people can go on developing
with them it's not a problem but the
question is what we are making available
going forward and I agree with you I
don't see the reason you know I'm trying
to understand I mean by the time we have
an LS TM layer and so on that's doing a
very complicated thing right and I don't
quite understand how that dovetails with
something which is a pure piece of code
or does it tell me no no so using it of
code with parameters inside yeah right
but LS TM layer is a complicated
creature with lots of different you know
inputs and outputs and so on is it not
yes yes right so it has to have a whole
Association worth of inputs the whole
Association worth of outputs right
defined by it if I'm not mistaken it has
one input and one output but it has many
parameters in that there are some Indian
input output which is the memory you can
expose the state for zoom in here okay
yeah the state port that is there is
hidden
when you can still access okay so
there's a question here for something
like this
what would this become would this become
in the model where there isn't a layer
object it's just a function what does
this function do and remember some
functions like the max function is not
trainable other functions are trainable
how do we represent that difference I
mean I would like to represent in the
code that we have write in a piece of
code here I'd like to know which things
here are trainable in this case the
linear layer right but all these things
here are not trainable you don't get to
train the tange function am I making
sense yeah and this is where it could be
a wrapper
what it could be a rapper like that what
identifies the trainable thing it's a
single symbol that contains well what is
trainable the fact is what's trainable
could be you know it is a you know what
is trainability mean it means there is a
you know a function that has parameters
basically and those parameters are
trainable as internal state that is
trainable yeah okay so I agree with you
I think that we need something which is
a generic you know thing that says you
know trainable something or other I mean
what is a linear layer if you were gonna
write a linear layer out in I mean you
know you could simply say you know we
could imagine something which has a
trainable array and our linear logistic
just B which is exactly what that array
is exactly right but so linear layer
could just be trainable array of blah
plus trainable array of blocks and and
you know there might be a shorthand for
writing that but fundamentally that's
what it is
there's also a great deal of
optimization that's yes right but but I
mean so if we did that then then this
whole function would be you know you
train it
it's trainable array would get set then
the whole function would run through
with the trainable array trained now
sometimes you might want to extract that
trainable array on its own from this
function and there would have to be a
mechanism for doing that but basically
this would clarify what on earth is
going on in this code if it just looked
like this which is exactly what MX let
is doing I think Jerome is it correct
but you have arrays that get trained
design yeah but I like that name
trainable array yeah it's explicit right
but but now okay so then but but but we
absolutely need some strings or
something that maps to the optimize
operations because do we want to line
yes right I mean so so the thing is
though that if I'm not mistaken I'm
still a little confused about how you
feed these things in these kind of sub
pieces to like the LS TM layer it's
amazing stuff like this actually works
it kind of is that is the marvel of
universality of computation so to speak
that even this you know kitchen sink
pile of gunk is trainable and and
computationally useful anyway sorry um
anyway um no III know what you mean
step step zero would be basically to
have something that looks very much like
the current layers just without the
clunkiness of the different symbols but
step one could be to rethink a bit about
this whole why don't we think about this
direction why don't we think about the
idea of having a you know something
called net layer which says you know
element-wise or whatever it is and has
you know something like this and which
could take or even maybe net function
could take string names as its instead
of an explicit form of function I'm not
sure but let's try and think about doing
it this way and think about what's
needed to access the relevant pieces
inside you know whether this is some
notify function that gives gives a named
piece inside here right that you're able
to access with net port didn't nobody
said that net layer is just that
function with a default setting no I
mean net layer linear is a customized
optimized net function yeah it could it
could equally well be net function of
you know linear like that yeah I mean
they semantically are not that different
no that would be the idea but but so the
other thing I was saying was that if you
want to be able to extract an innards
from a net function right that there's a
question of how you tag something in its
innards so that in the net function I
mean so what we're asking for is
normally you take in that function you
apply it to data and it gives output
right that's it's that's its basic mode
of operation but now what you're asking
for is things you're asking for you're
asking to be able to reach inside the
net function for essentially debugging
purposes and be able to pull something
out the net extract that's what we use
currently so only here you can extract
arrays Ethan is saying don't
overcomplicate things don't worry it
will be much simpler
this is how obligated an un simple yeah
it will be much simpler the his modeling
saying says he likes pie torch I you
know again I hope you guys can tell me
how you know what has been figured out
elsewhere um well the one thing that
figure it out is that for many network
is nicer to write them as a program yeah
which is what we were gonna do five
years ago I mean at the time the only
thing available was these blocks
essentially yeah um right yeah well so
the problem is okay so people talking
about tensorflow uh you know again I'm
not the expert in everybody else's
framework I just try and design hours
but it is my impression that those
things are much lower level than what we
have and pretty painful to use because
they don't automatically figure out
sizes of things and all those kinds of
things and that's that's what we've
managed to do nice and efficiently but
you know what we're saying here is that
we think we can generalize that to being
able to take these programs and figure
that stuff out for a program rather than
figuring it out just in terms of these
blocks so you know again let's repeat
here that the issue is we've got this
there are two things we want to be able
to achieve in addition one is reaching
inside for quotes debugging because it's
not something you can do in a typical
program I mean if I give you a typical
program and say I want to put a tap in
this place in the program how do I do
that
well the answer is I you know I have to
actually expose it somehow by changing
the code now what we want to do the
reason we don't want to do that here is
because the training step has already
been done
right so that that's the only reason we
wouldn't do you know essentially put an
echo in there am i making sense if we
had did you understand what I'm saying
yeah Jerome had an idea about echo that
you could use echo and I would create a
next report and I think implemented that
actually okay fine dandy but but but
that's at training time right the whole
point is you are handed a network right
and it is cheap to go in and say let me
put a tap inside this network it's a
bunch of you know it's a tangle of wires
and you're putting a crocodile clip on
one on one piece of it
right and that's cheap to do whereas in
an ordinary function in the language you
can put an echo in and you rerun the
function and it's all good and there's
no there's no giant training time or
compilation time associated with
preparing that function do you see what
I'm saying whereas here you could have
spent you know a thousand hours of
training time you don't want to retrain
it with a you know a new piece of code
that has the word echo in it am I making
sense
yeah okay right you need to add to a
train Network yeah right that's the
whole point that's why we can't use the
same mechanism that we use elsewhere in
the system right because elsewhere in
the system all we would do if we wanted
to put a sort of tap on this ramp we
would just say echo that ramp and it
would tell us those results or we would
say set some external variable and we
just rerun this and it's all good right
we don't know the property this can be
done with a property to say I want to I
mean no that's what it's doing right now
it has this net port mechanism right
that's the point I'm making that's the
reason we can't do it the most natural
way in our language would be to just go
and change the code right to say now I
want that port well we could imagine
that you BriTANicK own the code and that
keeps the train network and figure out
whether occasion it's possible and I
have to say I'm I'm somewhat favorable
to that because I think that the idea of
being able to point with your finger at
that cosine X thing in there is going to
be very difficult
in other words from outside the network
once it's been trained in this code
based way it's like oh I want the nth
part of this thing it's gonna be a total
mess so it would actually be better to
be able to if there was a way to do it
to take the code actually modify the
code to put in whatever you want to make
that to expose that port and you know
implementation lis I can see all kinds
of funky ways to do it with hash tables
and things like this to keep to keep a
hash of what you've already trained and
not have to retrain it I'm not sure if
that makes sense but you know the thing
that is difficult is given the given
this net function from the outside point
to that cosine to get what I'm saying
it's very straightforward when you're
looking at the code to point to it it's
very forward if you're from outside this
thing saying well I want the net port to
be the part seven comma three comma six
thing inside that piece of code
it seems very fragile
I mean um it depends I mean phone - it
depends what will be the workflow but
you could also do a graphic thing where
you click on this part of the code and
give you a path or something like that
um like it looking that I said you can
click right and you get that graph you
can click on parts and get the path yeah
okay fair enough fair enough okay so
that's an approach that that's a that's
a fallback approach net function linear
will have some some internal arrays that
have you know weights biases that
they're predefined so is like how do we
generalize it for net function function
that isn't that's not wrong I mean that
that's not relevant what you what you're
asking for is okay so what you're
suggesting is that the UX is you look at
the code you right-click on something
that tells you the path to the thing you
put that in and you know it's possible
it's possible or you have predefined it
with a wrapper inside which says you
know net name or something whatever
that's not the right word but net
tap um something like that and then you
know there's a named tap here you know
tap one or something yeah we're seeing
about that name collision is gonna be a
mess
what if you already have tough luck then
it's then it's gonna go wrong then it's
gonna give an error yeah okay we could
fail right I mean it that's it this is
you know what we're dealing with here is
you know
about code the good news is we've got a
symbolic language where we can talk
about code you know the bad news is it's
code you know code is intended to do
things it's not intended to be talked
about and you know it yeah anyway so
look it seems to me this is one problem
the other problem is the question of how
to get things that aren't just the
output a property here right that's the
other issue which you've been addressing
right and the point is that that I mean
insofar as we're going to something
where we're not talking about these
layers internally we don't have this
wacky thing where you could ask for the
property would will blow up if you did
am I making sense I mean to me the
correct way to do this for the property
is a headdress of some kind right the
correct way to do this is to say you
know something like net property I mean
this is a a Glee syntax but net probably
of you know top probabilities or
something of data so what I'm saying in
that would be the the clean semantics
way to do it because what you want is
not in fact net function applied to data
which just gives output but this meta
thing um applied yeah I mean
this is a if you evaluate the head alone
it could already tell you that it
doesn't exist or something like that
what do you mean like - if net function
linear does not support ah probabilities
you don't need the data to know it you
already know it well yes the network
then that property thing could just fail
out in that case even even without that
subuddhi thing but I think this is the
semantically correct way to do this now
you know we might have some sugar that
makes it slightly simpler but I think
that's the correct way to do it except
that's way less nice and just this is
gonna argue me I don't care I mean we it
doesn't matter I mean we can that that's
not the thing we're trying to solve the
first thing we need to solve is what
what is that what is the full structure
that we want then we can figure out I
mean if this is really like an entity it
could be another sub value net function
applied on top probabilities applied on
data that's very similar to like net
property entity comma property sure so
anyway applied on property yes it could
do that that's okay you know there are
variety of syntactic things but the most
important thing to understand is what is
the what is the underlying structure and
this seems to be the right underlying
structure to me
so okay look let's just review for a
second I've got to go I'm now
two-and-a-half meetings late I'm the
okay so we've got this idea of the low
level trainable array we've got this
idea of the net function with possibly
named functions in there that correspond
to our existing layers we've got this
matter idea here um and we've got an
idea as yet rather undefined for doing
general functional programming with the
indication of what what gets made as a
block in the block diagram um we've also
got we're failing to get to things like
compiled layer which I'm sure is very
lovely
oh that looks very nice um that's for
another time this is we've already
talked about this we already talked
about this yeah but we didn't finish
yeah actually you might be confusing
with every reduce which we talk a lot
but we're skiing we talked a little bit
but we talked a bit about this and it
was very nice what we figured out here
is really nice yeah but yeah there's a
new thing is what would be the second
argument to specify the convention and
we had an idea of putting a little spec
so one would be that's that's not we're
not gonna resolve this right now this is
a more complicated story oh um okay all
right um by the way for people on live
streaming bit little less than hour I'm
doing a completely different thing I'm
doing a Science and Technology Q&A for
kids and others don't ask about net
functions they're wrong topic um the
something recreational for me at least
um
okay all right well we're making good
progress here let me let me make sure I
send you this notebook because this
isn't stored in the usual place um and
good um okay thanks a lot so to be
continued
um okay I